[Music]
fury asked me to come up here and see
how you were doing he just he felt bad
about snapping at ya really you guys do
have sarcasm on this earth right how you
feeling I didn't think I was gonna have
to save the world this summer I know
that makes me sound like such a jerk I
just I had this plan with this girl that
I'm really liking how it's all ruined I
like you Peter a good kid there's a part
of me that wants me to tell you just
turn around run away from all this and
then there's another part of me that
knows what we're about to fight what's
at stake I'm glad you're here
me too but you're worried about your
friends
yeah just always feel like I'm putting
them in danger look just get him inside
and keep me in a safe place for just a
few hours and they'll be all right
it's really nice to have somebody to
talk to you about superhero stuff you
know anytime everywhere I go I see his
face just really miss him
yeah miss him too I don't think Tony
would have done what he did if he didn't
know that you were gonna be here after
he was gone
you gonna be a next Ironman now well no
I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
look keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation
[Music]
heads up Nick Fury's calling me I don't
really want to talk to me that's all why
because if you don't talk to him and I
have to talk I don't want to talk about
you sent Nick Fury to voicemail I gotta
go you do not ghost Nick Fury darts
what's up
we're just talking about the trip oh I
think MJ really likes me
when I first I'm alone you're a very
difficult person to contact spider-man
this is mr. Veeck we're gonna use
someone like you on my world new world
Beck is from Earth just not house a snap
to our home in our dimension we have a
job to do
you're coming with us
it's gotta be something else you can use
what about Thor offworld
captain I'm unavailable but who's the
funny neighborhood spider-man [ __ ]
please you've been to space what do you
want Peter I want to go back on my trip
with the girl you I really like you tell
her how I feel MJ I am spider-man no of
course not I mean it's kind of obvious
you're right you may not be ready but
this is my responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifices
sometimes people die
so I feel like I putting my friends in
danger
the world needs next Ironman you're
going to step up or not
[Music]
here I work with spider-man you were
through Slayer
I want what spider-man not for
spider-man
[Music]